[Musique]
d
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 19 novembre à
nouveau point presse hebdomadaire
d'olivier verrons tout est leur
l'inquiétude se porte désormais sur la
souffrance psychologique des français
lié à l'épidémie
côté vaccins le gouvernement voudrait
bien ne pas rater le virage de la
vaccination mais la france sera t elle
prête en temps et en heure pour
organiser une grande campagne de
vaccination le poids de l'europe
va-t-il être un frein les français
seront ils au rendez vous ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face
et l'une des autres conséquences de
cette crise sanitaire dont on parle peu
la dette des entreprises qui ne cesse de
grimper dans quelle mesure cet
endettement menace-t-il la reprise
espérée l'année prochaine est une bombe
à retardement pour l'économie
des questions auxquelles jacques sapir
tentera de répondre tout à l'heure la
crise sanitaire à l'échelle mondiale
plus de 56 millions de cad coronavirus
au total sur la planète
ces dernières 24 heures le nombre de
contaminations et de décès comptabilisés
est au plus haut depuis le début de la
pandémie si des signes encourageants
commencent à être visibles en europe
l'épidémie repart à la hausse aux états
unis illustration à new york où les
écoles referme leurs portes à partir
d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
olivier verront donc tenu tout à l'heure
le point presse hebdomadaire sur
l'évolution de l'épidémie les précisions
avec notre reporter katia technique
l'intervention d'olivier véran a ciblé
la santé mentale diverses figures de la
psychologie ou de la psychiatrie s'était
exprimée récemment dans les médias
ils dénonçaient le manque d'initiative
l'arrêt de certaines démarches également
le manque d'information pour les
français qui souffrent de problèmes
psychologiques qui souffre de dépression
durant ce second confinement alors
olivier ferrand a évoqué les souffrances
psychiques des français actuellement
c'est-à-dire l'incertitude face à
l'avenir notamment pour les étudiants
l'angoissé d'être malade
l'isolément pour les personnes âgées ou
encore les problèmes posés par le
télétravail aussi l'angoissent de ceux
qui ne travaillent plus et puis
évidemment
n'oublions pas les patients qui
souffrait déjà de problèmes
psychiatriques alors olivier ferrand a
expliqué que le gouvernement était très
préoccupé par ces soucis qu'il avait
déjà mis des initiatives sur place
durant la première vague pour aider les
français qui souffre pas de troubles
psychologiques qui souffrent de
dépression
je vous propose de l'écouter à ce sujet
sur des initiatives qui sont d'ailleurs
pour certaines en cours de réalisation
quarante et une cellule d'urgence
médico-psychologique ont été dotés de
moyens supplémentaires avec des binômes
psychologues infirmiers et rien que pour
la première vague ces cellules ont
assuré 8000 de prise en charge de
personnes qui étaient en demande
160 psychologue supplémentaires sont
actuellement en cours de recrutement
dans les centres médico psychologiques
avec elisabeth bornes
conscient du fait que le télétravail
peut être pesant nous avons réactivé le
numéro vert le numéro que je vous
redonne qui est important le 0 800 100
30 0000 830 000
jérôme salomon le directeur de la santé
et olivier ferrand ont également fait un
point sur l'épidémie à proprement parler
alors ils ont rappelé qu'il y avait 47
me
27 morts depuis le début de l'épidémie
2200 malades hospitalisés en 24 heures
alors le nombre de cas en france reste
élevé mais il y a de quoi se réjouir
puisque il y à un ralentissement observé
de la circulation du virus tout
toutefois la pression sanitaire reste
élevée avec une situation préoccupante
dans la région où vergne rhône alpes une
charge hospitalière très forte c'est
pourquoi olivier véran incite les
français à redoubler d'efforts et à ne
pas relâcher leur vigilance
durant ce second confinement et pour en
parler nous sommes avec fabrice di vizio
avocat spécialiste des professions de
santé bon soir fabrice di vizio merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
olivier ferrand qui a consacré
aujourd'hui son point presse on
conséquences psychologiques il est vrai
que les français sont plus dépressifs
qu'avant par aman les dépressions ont
doublé ces deux derniers mois une
stratégie claire aurait pu éviter cela
selon vous on sait que le flou on n'est
jamais très apprécié par les populations
je crois d'abord qu'il faut bien se
souvenir que nous avons un gouvernement
anxiogène que franchement pas être
dépressif après les neuf mois qui vient
de traverser avec jérôme salomon qui
venez vous dire tous les soirs égrainé
les morts avec le président de la
république nous explique on est en
guerre qui maintenant vous expliquer
avec 9000 morts attendu que arrête tout
on a un gouvernement anxiogène la
panique de ce gouvernement a forcément
rejaillit sur les populations les plus
fragiles et les plus exposés donc nous
avons un gouvernement qui est à
l'origine par sa propre communication
déjà effectivement d'un certain nombre
de troubles psychologiques majeurs
il a angoissé les populations il a mis
les populations en panique relayé en
cela par une partie du corps médical qui
se succédaient sur les plateaux télé et
qui au nom de la prise de conscience
virait à la dictature de l'émotion nous
sommes devenus fous mais vraiment
littéralement cette communication du
gouvernement j insiste une nouvelle fois
va conduire à des morts et peut-être
encore plus que le co lead
alors c'est vrai que
fait l'avocat du diable mais peut-être
que les français n'ont pas toujours
respecté les règles on l'a vu cet été
est ce que le gouvernement n'a pas été
obligée peut-être de jouer la peur pour
tenter de le convaincre de remporter
l'adhésion
vous savez madame la peur celle arnaud
du faible
la raison moderne du fort d'abord c'est
pas vrai que les français n'ont pas
respecté ce qui nous ont encouragés à
partir en vacances c'est les gouvernants
eux mêmes ce qui effectivement a géré le
déconfinement n'importe comment
c'est le premier ministre lui-même quant
à vos images là que je dois en même
temps que je parle qu'elle est dans
l'intérêt est ce que vous faites ça pour
le cancer est ce que vous voulez qu'on
montre effectivement des patients
atteints du cancer
vous voulez qu'on voit des poumons
noircis par le tabac pourquoi on fait
pas ça alors pour toutes les pathologies
il y à une dictature de l'émotion qui
fait emparé de ce qu been parce que
soyons clairs et soyons honnêtes c'est
une aubaine incroyable c'est une aubaine
incroyable pour les médias qui ont des
choses à montrer
regardez effectivement ce qu'on boira
moment où je vous parle c'est une
aubaine incroyable pour le gouvernement
parce qu'en instaurant une dictature de
la peur et les modificateurs de
l'émotion il arrive à des fins qu on ne
devrait même pas imaginer dans le pire
des scénarios
on va arriver progressivement un vaccin
ou avec un espoir de se faire vacciner
contre une pathologie qui finalement
fait un nombre de morts quand même donc
il faut se souvenir du chiffre comme
très relatif on ne sait rien de ce
vaccin
mais c'est pas grave on va se faire
vacciner quand même et si vous voulez
qu'on soit vacciné et adhérer à des
mesures totalement absurde et de plus en
plus attentatoires aux libertés et bien
qu'une solution jouer sur la peur et ça
marche quand je vais je vais vous
taquinez puisque vous nous taquiner
c'est une aubaine aussi pour les avocats
puisque vous êtes vous portez les
plantes de nombreux soignants contre le
gouvernement dans cette gestion de
l'épidémie où vous en êtes quelles sont
vos chances justement de deux succès
dans ses plaintes parce qu'il ya ça
aussi peut-être on le dit souvent qu'ils
poussent aussi le gouvernement à sortir
le parapluie
ces plaintes au pénal que les ministres
subissent ils ne prennent pas les bonnes
décisions
je vais quand même répondre à l'effet
d'aubaine
les avocats en vous expliquant que moi
je m'en serais bien passé de ces
plaintes en vous expliquant qu
effectivement si nous avions un
gouvernement qui avait à peu près gérer
la crise correctement et que nous
n'avions pas eu imiterait santé qui
était venu nous expliquer qu'elle savait
tout avant tout le monde
eh bien je me serais bien passé de ces
plaintes je me serais bien placé passé
d'avoir des soignants au mois de mars
qui allaient dans les hôpitaux
apparemment avec un virus ô combien
mortel sans masque je me serais bien
passé d'avoir présenté des familles de
soignants décédé soyez sûr que je m'en
serais bien passé et que les soignants
décédé se serait bien passé également
effectivement de cette situation quant à
la question de savoir où nous en sommes
dans les plinthes et bien les plaintes
sont en cours la cour de justice de la
république
vous le savez effectivement a fait des
perquisitions ces perquisitions sont en
train d'être exploitée nous avons le
parquet de paris qui a ouvert une
information judiciaire et nous avons
effectivement une plainte contre jean
castex qui a été rejetée l'arrière parce
que celle-ci émanait d'une association
qui estime ton n'a pas d'intérêt à agir
et n'a pas effectivement de légitimité
et bien c'est pas grave je vous annonce
très officiellement que entre demain et
lundi environ 1000 plaintes vont être
déposées contre jean castex par des
citoyens excédés de cette situation
excédé d'être pris pour des imbéciles en
permanence
excédé d'être infantilisés et excédé
qu'on joue sur leur peur puisque la
seule chose effectivement ce
gouvernement comprend c'est la justice
parce que c'est la seule voie qui nous
reste et bien nous la ferons valoir
mais nous allons je termine là dessus
droit dans le mur et à une vitesse qu'on
ne soupçonne pas alors il ya désormais
la lueur on va dire et l'espoir d'un
vaccin
le gouvernement espère bien ne pas
louper le coche cette fois-ci vous êtes
confiant quant à la stratégie du
gouvernement pour mener à bien une
campagne massive de vaccination
prochainement je dirais je pense que
pardon mais la personne qui fait encore
confiance à ce gouvernement c'est
qu'elle souffre d'un vrai problème
psychiatrique cirque et c'est une
décompensation psychiatrique c'est pas
possible autrement
je dire que ce gouvernement puisse
effectivement nous mener vers une
campagne de vaccination si ils gèrent
cette campagne de vaccination et si ce
vaccin est aussi fiable qui le dit
effectivement et que ses paroles a
autant de poids que celles qu'elle a eu
tous ces derniers mois eh ben je vais
vous dire on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge
alors si vous me demandez est-ce que
j'ai confiance dans le gouvernement pour
quoi que ce soit la réponse est non
absolument pour rien et encore moins
pour la vaccination
absolument pas on est en train de jouer
avec quoi avec cette vaccination c'est à
qui mieux mieux y en a un qui vous dit
que les vacciner le vaccin efficace à
95% l'autre à 97% dire qu'est ce qu'on
est en train de faire mise à part
engraisser l'industrie pharmaceutique
dans cette affaire je vois pas ce qu'on
est en train de faire on a une courbe
épidémique qu'un train de redescendre
on a courbé qui débite 40 se stabilise
et on voit bien qu effectivement les
mesures ont servi à rien je suis désolé
beaucoup avaient beaucoup frère de lci
donc parfaitement montré hier soir avec
des courbes très significative qui
montre que tout ça a commencé à baisser
de manière flagrante et comme le disait
le professeur rajoute d'ailleurs au
passage bien avant le confinement bien
avant les mesures de couvre-feu et donc
on voit bien qu'on est sur une épidémie
ou non connais pas grand chose et qui
manifestement est en train de se tarir
et on se précipite sur des vaccins comme
la misère sur le pauvre monde mais on
est devenu complètement fou on est
devenus fous et après pardon je termine
on vous fait une histoire que la
chloroquine dont il paraît que c'est pas
prouvée cetera
on fait des histoires incommensurable
avec un traitement vieux de près de 100
ans dire et là on vient effectivement
donné son adhésion à un vaccin qu'une
avec une innovation thérapeutique dont
personne ne maîtrise la nature mais on
est devenu complètement fou on est donc
j'ai un état où on est malhonnête ou on
est juste complètement fou mais c'est
l'un ou l'autre
j'espère effectivement on est juste fou
merci fabrice des misions avant 4-2
soignants et le professeur awa le thé et
croyez-nous egan
les médias c'est pas une partie de
plaisir on se serait bien passé aussi
d'égréner ses chiffres de morts et de
parler voilà autant de temps de cette
épidémie qui nous peinent tous merci à
vous en tout cas fabrice sa division
alors comment la france se
prépare-t-elle à l'arrivée de ce vaccin
dont on vient de parler si le
gouvernement annonce avoir commandé des
congélateurs destinée à conserver les
dos pour le moment l'hexagone reste
suspendue à d'autorisation de la
commission européenne la préparation
reste pour l'instant logistique les
explications d'emilie gong h nous nous
préparons et nous anticipons l'arrivée
d'un vaccin à l'anticipation maître mot
du gouvernement 90 millions de doses
auraient déjà été réservés elle devrait
être livrée pour la nouvelle année votée
dans le budget 2021 de la sécurité
sociale un milliard et demi d'euros sera
entre autres consacré à cet achat mais
avant cela la france doit attendre
l'aval de l'agencé européenne du
médicament
on se met dans les starting blocks pour
distribuer un vaccin dès lors que
celui-ci aura bénéficié des
autorisations et des validations par les
autorités scientifiques nationales et
internationales
l' agence européenne du médicament a dit
qu'elle pensait pouvoir donner une
validation à un premier vaccin la fin de
l'année pour qu'ils puissent être
distribués à partir du mois de janvier
après l'autorisation de l'agencé
européenne du médicament la france devra
aussi obtenir l'aval de la commission
européenne
car c'est à bruxelles que sera évaluée
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
la commission se base sur l'évaluation
scientifique réalisée par l' agence
européenne du médicament avant que la
procédure n'arrive à son terme
reste donc à la france la possibilité de
se préparer à l'arrivée d'un vaccin est
selon le ministre de la santé
le chantier est monumentale nous avons
d'ores et déjà acheté par exemple par
exemple que je vous donne 50 super
congélateur qui permettent de stocker à
moins 80 degrés des produits de santé
qui seront reliés à des alarmes qui
seront entreposés dans des temps dans
des endroits sécurisés à partir desquels
des équipes vont se déployer pour
ensuite alimenter tous ceux qui seront
amenés à vacciner etc c'est un chantier
qui monumentale de charge de la
vaccination
le vaccin concerné pour l'instant celui
de father et bio ntech à
ans ponctuelle d'un géant américain et
d'une société de biotechnologie
allemande dans d'autres pays le remède
fait son entrée plus rapidement aux
etats unis 20 millions de personnes
pourraient être vaccinés avant la fin de
l'année la société américaine moderna
devrait voir la commercialisation de son
vaccin autorisé dès le début du mois de
décembre en chine environ un million de
personnes ont reçu une dose d'un vaccin
expérimental produit par sinopharm group
pharmaceutique d'état sur le continent
africain le maroc qu'a également choisie
le vaccin chinois ainsi qu'un vaccin
britannique le royaume devrait team
unies'' et sa population dès le mois
prochain et les autorités elle en tout
cas ne veulent pas rater le virage dans
la vaccination mais la france sera t
elle prête en temps et en heure pour
organiser une campagne massive de
vaccination le poids de l'europe
va-t-elle va-t-il être un frein les
français seront ils eux mêmes au
rendez-vous place à notre décryptage
avec nos invités
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
morgane mouly vice-présidente syndicat
des jeunes biologistes médicaux bonsoir
morgan boulistes merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france arnaud chiche
anesthésistes réanimateurs médical
fondateur du collectif santé en danger
bonsoir à vous également un hochet merci
d'être avec nous donc 47 candidats
vaccins sont en ce moment testé à
travers le monde plusieurs dizaine de
firmes pharmaceutiques sont engagés dans
la recherche c'est une course qui
suscite évidemment des appétits ans
fabrice di vizio le critiquer ardemment
tout à l'heure il faut au contraire se
réjouit de cette mobilisation morgan
moulis effectivement après ben on espère
vraiment que la france sera au rendez
vous comme vous l'avez dit d'abord nous
attendons le feu vert de l'union
européenne pour vraiment valider un
vaccin je pense qu'au gouvernement ne
peut vraiment pas s'en passer pour
garantir la sécurité puisque en bois qu
aucun des problèmes et la logistique
mais le deuxième problème est qu'il ya
des ions des français cette vaccination
et les derniers sondages ne sont pas du
tout en faveur d'une envie des français
de se vacciner donc un double défi pour
le gouvernement avec effectivement une
première étape de validation et de
sécurisation du vaccin par région
européenne du médicament
la multiplication de ces annonces
fighter moderna c'est une bonne nouvelle
arnaud chichou vous rester méfiant c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle parce que
quand même les infectiologues disent
bien que pour avoir une chance de
d'éradiquer le qu il est en tout cas de
pouvoir vivre avec lui il faut de la
stratégie vaccinale est forcément une
bonne stratégie est donc que j'ai
l'habitude de faire confiance à mes
experts après il est certain que les
annonces vont très vite et on a besoin
d'avoir la totalité des chiffres on a
besoin aussi d'avoir des informations un
petit peu plus précise
combien d'injection il faudra faire et
ce qui aura besoin de faire des rappels
est-ce que ce vaccin protégera aussi
bien les personnes âgées et les jeunes
on a besoin d'avoir les résultats de
toutes ses études
donc prudence un optimisme prudent
pour reprendre une expression très à la
mode alors en tout cas la france espère
bien ne pas louper le coche intra
critiquée sur sa gestion de la pandémie
pour le moment olivier ferrand le
martèle notre pays se prépare pour
commencer une campagne de vaccination
débute 2021 je vous propose d'écouter le
ministre de la santé
il y à un laboratoire qui a communiqué
des données intermédiaires suite à son
étude clinique en population générale
aux agences américaines et européennes
du médicament
on espère que d'ici trois semaines le
laboratoire en question files heures
aura donné la totalité de ces données
scientifiques qui permettront à ces deux
agences de faire une analyse rapide des
données et de nous dire si oui ou non on
peut commencer à instruire des dossiers
à l'échelle d'un pays en vue de vacciner
oui dans le même temps une distribution
du vaccin à biot ntech fighter est
possible cette année c'est ce qu'a
indiqué tout à l'heure le pdg de bio
tech l'agencé france presse
morgane ou lisse vous y croyez justement
cette campagne de vaccination des bulles
des buts de 1021 vous êtes optimiste on
ne peut qu'être mais comme le dit le
ministre il ya des études qui ont été
faites mais elles sont encore
intermédiaire nous n'avons encore eu
aucun retour sur d'éventuels effets
indésirables
ce qui intéresse principalement quand
même les français
voilà donc on attend des résultats
définitifs des études fortement
concluant que ce que le chiffre qui a
été un petit peu donnaient ressemble
plutôt à un effet d'annonce peut-être
une petite aide aux marchés financiers
on va donc on attend vraiment des
résultats scientifiques probants et à ce
moment là effectivement nous seront
favorables et on espère que le
gouvernement ce sera assez préparé pour
que dès que nous ayons eu le feu vert
nous puissions voilà déployer cette
campagne de vaccination avec un maximum
d'adhésions des français et il est vrai
que qui vaccinera c'est encore une
question en tout cas nous les
biologistes médicaux qui a montré qu'on
était capable de faire les choses de
manière massive ces derniers mois sont
prêts à vraiment participer à la
campagne de vaccination avec tours et
matériels locaux adaptés pour le faire
alors il ya les autorisations évidemment
d
les autorités de santé en france mais il
ya aussi l'europe
je vous propose d'écouter en sont de
stéphane bancel le pdg de modern art
c'est l'un des candidats qui fait la
course en tête également pour distribuer
ce vaccin écouter justement il parle de
ses problèmes de négociations avec les
différents pays européens
on discute avec beaucoup de pays
d'europe depuis le mois de mai mais nous
n'avons aucune signature de contrats
le vaccin est sur le point d'être
approuvé par les autorités sanitaires
européennes
ce serait dommage qu'aucun pays ne
puisse en disposer arnaud chiche c'est
assez édifiant cette interview du pdg de
moderna il explique que voilà il a
négocié et déjà dealé aulas a négocié ce
vaccin avec plusieurs pays l'italie
israël le japon mais voilà ça ça coince
avec beaucoup de pays d'europe dont la
france justement il parle lui même du
poids de l'administration européenne
c'est quelque chose dont nous français
il faut qu'on s'inquiète aujourd'hui
dont il faut qu'on s'inquiète je sais
que je sais pas madame je sais pas assez
c'est bon je ne sais pas et c'est des
informations qui sont très anxiogène
pour les français je sais pas si c'est
très je sais pas c'est un chef
d'entreprise c'est bien ça lance un
représentant du latran ils essaient de
deux modèles n'a toute façon on sait
être la bureaucratie elle existe un en
europe et en france
après bon j'espère que je compte quand
j'entends le ministre olivier ferrand il
a l'air quand même de tout faire pour
qu'on puisse mettre le pays en quatre
ans situation de vacciner une fois qu'on
aura des informations sérieuses sur ce
fameux vaccin et qu'on se rassure qui
aura pas d'effets secondaires et
d'effets indésirables
donc en fait j'ai quand même envie de
suivre la dynamique de l'exode du
gouvernement sur ce point là et puis
peut-être que s'il aura pour si ce
monsieur il a du mal à avoir des retours
directs et bien ya peut-être des raisons
il ya peut-être que c'est peut-être que
les données sont pas sont pas
suffisantes pour pour la france et que
y'a vous allez on va déjà très très vite
on va déjà très très vite on sait que
les procédures ont été accélérées et
bien écoutez on
je pense que vouloir aller vite c'est
bien grillé toutes les étapes c'est
forcément pas bien il faut je crois que
pour qu'on puisse avoir une adhésion la
plus importante possible à ce vaccin
faut que les choses elle soit à ces eaux
limpides et et bien moi j'ai quand même
envie de faire confiance dans les
autorités dans nos autorités parce que
vous voyez conférence de presse
aujourd'hui les infos sont claires en
commande les congélateurs et c'est donc
ça a l'air d'être voilà on veut aller
vite quoi donc dès qu'il y en aura un
qui donnera satisfaction je pense que la
france elle saura dire elle saura dire
est passé les bonnes commandes
c'est vrai qu'au maroc la campagne a été
annoncée pendant quinze jours avec
astrazeneca et le fameux vaccin chinois
ordonnée par le roi mohamed 6 à dubaï où
la vie ensemble
revenu à la normale les restaurants sont
sont actuellement ouverts les me
renvoyer n'hésitent pas à se faire
photographier en se faisant vacciner
c'était le 3 novembre précisément
toujours le vexin chinois morgan moulis
à vous avez une réaction quand vous
voyez ce genre d'image ça veut dire quoi
comme le dit arnaud chiche c'est bien on
est prudent en france on va on se donne
le temps il faut être prudent ou au
contraire voilà pourquoi il ya des pays
qui ont déjà débuté des vaccinations et
pas d'autres exactement c'est un choix
qu'ont fait certains pays de commencer à
vacciner avant d'avoir des résultats
définitifs sont les différents vaccins
candidats moi je pense que la france
fait bien être prudente
voilà comme l'a dit mon collègue au
vaccin a été fait très rapidement avoir
beaucoup plus rapidement que les
précédents vaccin pour d'autres
pathologies
donc il convient d'attendre vraiment les
résultats définitifs avant de commencer
à vacciner et je pense que la russie la
chine comme d'autres pays vont peut-être
un petit peu trop vite
voilà il faut quand même franchir les
étapes de sécurisation de vaccins de
garantie à la fois de la fiabilité et du
peu d'effet indésirable
petit à petit il faut vraiment respecté
toutes les étapes avant de vraiment à ce
moment-là déployer massivement le vaccin
est une chose est sûre c'est que la
prudence votre présent semble partagé
par beaucoup de deux français
bonne nouvelle pour beaucoup d'entre eux
mais pour d'autres c'est plutôt le 7
nice ils sont écoutés je pense dans tous
les cas ça conditionne la sortie du
confinement donc pour en finir avec ce
cirque je compte me faire vacciner le
plus tôt possible et j'espère que tout
le monde en fera de même pour qu'on
puisse enfin sortir efficaces ou non peu
importe
l'excellent phyllis quoi pour l'instant
je pense que c'est pas encore abouti on
cherche un vaccin à tout prix rapidement
mais
ça pour ça qu'il est encore qui peut
être vraiment efficace mais on n'en sait
rien pour l'instant donc je prendrais
pas le risque ça c'est sûr la presse et
chacun voit qu'ils veulent pas faire ne
pas le faire moi je le ferai parce que
j'ai eu quand même j'ai 66 ans une
personne dans la fragilité de ma santé
et je le ferai c'est très
franco-français de ne pas mettre le mas
de mettre le masque que de tout de tout
refuser en première instance et puis
après tout le monde doit s'y faire je
pense que tout le monde va le faire on a
peu de chances qu'on n'a pas le choix
non plus arnaud aussi ce scepticisme
purement français c'est quelque chose
que vous vous explique t on vous
explique et bien je sais pas très
nouveau ça on sait que les français ils
ont peu sont pas forcément très
favorable aux vaccins c'est d'ailleurs
un vrai problème
il ya des parents qui veulent pas se
faire vacciner leurs enfants et puis
c'est comme ça qu'il a parfois des
cerlatez résurgence de maladies
normalement éradiquer qui sont
catastrophiques
voilà après à la décharge des français
on peut pas dire que les deux crises qu
dit qu'on ait vécu en france se soit
passé dans la sérénité la plus totale et
en ce qui concerne des soignants en tout
cas je comme vous le savez j'ai fondé un
collectif de soignants qui réclame de
l'aide de l'aide à l'hôpital pour gérer
ça y est peut-être que ya un climat un
petit peu de scepticisme dans la
communication du gouvernement
il ya eu aussi quelques petits problèmes
ces derniers mois et ces apu peut-être
faire douter mais je pense aussi que il
suffit de manière très pédagogique en
ayant une communication positive
rassurante avant tout factuelle en
s'appuyant sur des choses sur des
résultats d'études sérieuses les études
qui ont été faites pour le vaccin
il s'agira de rassurer les français et
puis surtout de bien leur expliquer que
c'est dans l'intérêt de tous comme l'ont
dit certains de vos deux des gens qui
ont été interrogés c'est dans l'intérêt
de tous de pouvoir redémarrer l'économie
et que si le vaccin est retenu par nos
experts infectiologues comme étant une
piste pour toi éradiquer ce virus et
qu'on reprenne tous une vie un peu
normal bien je crois que
on pourra alors laissé le temps aussi de
se faire un idée et puis peu à peu
contre les gens sales sinon on verra
bien qui se passe peut-être pas grand
chose et puis que d'un seul coup ça
donnera ça motivera tout le monde
en tout cas il faut essayer de
communiquer positivement merci beaucoup
en tout cas tous les deux morgan money
cerneaux chiche d'avoir été avec nous
dit réactionnaire t france dans quelques
instants rester avec nous parlerons de
la dette des entreprises qui ne cesse de
monter avec cette crise sanitaire
jacques sapir tentera de répondre à
cette question
est ce une bombe à retardement pour
l'économie et puis nous reviendrons sur
cette deuxième vague de l'épidémie à
l'échelle mondiale cette fois ci avec
des nouvelles comme à new york les
écoles qui referme à partir
d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et
de taille shamikha recrutés dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo
clou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
et semis et c'est un peu le passage de
relais d'al qaïda l'état islamique
quelques pas dans notre politique
internationale began évident qu'il faut
pas créer les conditions à nouveau une
terre de jihad et de cet appel d'air
justement on recrutement l'a
malheureusement fait en syrie en irak
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alexandre je faisais direct vous êtes
vous déjà dopé il n'y a jamais de ma vie
[Musique]
vous pensiez que la sphère du dopage en
russie était terminée pour vous trompiez
les documents sont arrivés et que j'ai
ouvert le dossier et j'ai eu
l'impression d'être recouverts de boue
la participation des athlètes russes aux
compétitions internationales est en jeu
cela concerne notamment des événements
tels que les jeux olympiques de tokyo et
la coupe du monde de football au qatar
c'est ma médaille je sais que je les
gagne honnêtement je ne rendrai jamais
comme il y a quatre ans le laboratoire
antidopage de moscou est au centre de ce
scandale
alors qui a modifié la base de données
d'échantillons des sportifs et quel
rapport cela a t-il avec grigoriy
rodtchenko off
ils ont pu remplacer des résultats
négatifs par des résultats positifs
comme si l'athlète avait déjà consommé
des substances interdites pour
l'approcher par la suite et le faire
chanter pour de l'argent
je
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus
c'est en direct sur rt france les
derniers chiffes du courant des virus en
france santé publique france dénombre en
24 heures 18 1979 nouveaux cas confirmés
par test pcr et 2171 cas confirmés par
test antigénique 436 personnes sont
décédées à l'hôpital ces dernières 24
heures le taux de positivité des tests
s'établit désormais à 15,5 pour cent est
l'une des conséquences de cette crise
sanitaire dont on parle peu la dette des
entreprises qui ne cesse de grimper dans
quelle mesure ces d'enfants menace-t-il
la reprise espérée l'année prochaine est
ce une bombe à retardement pour
l'économie
on en parle tout de suite avec notre
économiste jacques sapir bonsoir jacques
merci d'être avec nous bonsoir stéphanie
alors est-il vrai jacques que les
entreprises ont accumulé beaucoup de
dettes avec l'épidémie et que cela
pourrait compromettre même la reprise
oui c'est fini c'est tout à fait évident
et il faut comprendre c'est que les
entreprises françaises se voit
évidemment leur endettement s'accroître
avec la crise sanitaire
il ya des chaînes d'endettement qui sont
en train de se constituer par rapport
aux fournisseurs par rapport aux sous
traitants mais aussi par rapport aux
banques alors c'est en partie le
résultat de la politique de soutien du
gouvernement qui a privilégié d'une
certaine manière les crédits les crédits
garantis aux subventions
l'important dans cette histoire c'est
que le chiffre d'affaires des
entreprises est en train de baisser et
en tous les cas ne retrouvant pas le
niveau de 2019 et bien évidemment ça ne
permettra pas aux entreprises de
rembourser ou ne serait-ce que de faire
face financièrement à cette dette donc
oui effectivement il y à bien un risque
sur la reprise à venir
alors jacques comment l'endettement des
entreprises at il progressé justement
ces derniers temps c'est dans cet
endettement s'est énormément accrue
on a aujourd'hui les chiffres qui sont
donnés par la banque de france et on
voit de ce point de vue là que
l'endettement a augmenté d'environ 10%
en quelques mois de février à août de
cette année donc oui c'est quelque chose
de tout à fait considérable 10% de plus
d'endettement et c'est d'autant plus
considérable que le chiffre d'affaires
des entreprises
évidemment n'a pas progressé il a même
régressé il s'est contractée de manière
extrêmement importante avec le premier
et maintenant avec le 2ème confinement
donc ça veut dire que la capacité des
entreprises à rembourser leurs dettes
c'est en réalité dégradé et ça c'est
évidemment quelque chose de très
inquiétant alors quelles sont les
entreprises qui se sont le plus endetté
pas c'est pas étonnant ce sont
essentiellement les petites et moyennes
entreprises ce qu'on appelle les pme il
faut comprendre que dans le confinement
qu'on avait subi au printemps et qu'on
est en train à nouveau de subir mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans le
premier confinement le premier et femmes
oui le premier mois les grandes
entreprises se sont précipités sur les
aides offertes par le gouvernement mais
ensuite on voit que ce sont ce qu'on
appelle les pme et les pays autrement
dit les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire qui se sont massivement
endettés et et qui ont continué en fait
de s'endetter pratiquement jusqu'au mois
de juillet ce qui fait que le stock de
dette s'est fortement accrue et
justement dans des entreprises
que ce soit les pme où que ce soit les
pays dont la capacité à faire face à ses
frais financiers et bien n'est pas du
tout évidente
jack que cela est dû à la politique de
l'état en partie en partie seulement
bien entendu la première cause de cet
endettement
c'est la contraction de l'activité
économique que les entreprises ont subi
d'abord avec la crise sanitaire dans son
ensemble et puis avec évidemment les
confinements mai
la décision politique de l'état c'est
bien une décision politique de jouer
essentiellement sur la dimension des
crédits des crédits garantis et vous
savez la france comme d'ailleurs
d'autres pays d'europe 1 comme le
royaume uni comme l'italie comme
l'allemagne
mais justement ce n'est pas la situation
que l'on connaît
en outre et aux états unis la france a
décidé de faire jouer à ce crédit donc
aux banques le rôle principal dans la
politique de soutien aux entreprises
c'est ce qui a permis en fait que se
constitue un stock de dette tout à fait
impressionnant et on peut se demander
aujourd'hui si en poussant les
entreprises à s'endetter
le gouvernement n'avait pas fait à
l'époque le pari d'une reprise rapide
or la progression de l'épidémie montre
que ce pari est à l'évidence perdu et ça
pourquoi pensez-vous que cela risque
précisément de compromettre la relance
et il ya deux raisons la première c'est
évidemment que des entreprises qui
auraient pu autrement survivre à leur
endettement
face à ce surcroît d'endettement
engendrée par la crise sanitaire là ne
pourront pas justement survivre on se
trouve est condamné a fait ça c'est le
premier point mais il ya aussi le cas
des entreprises qui vont survivre on
espère qu'elles seront les plus
nombreuses donc les entreprises et qui
vont survivre elles vont devoir faire un
effort particulier pour rembourser leurs
dettes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire un effort
particulier c'est à dire que dame d'une
part elles vont évidemment augmenter
leurs prix et d'autre part elles vont
sacrifier l'investissement ce qui en
réalité va compromettre leur survie dans
une économie qui est largement au
compétitive et largement ouverte à la
compétition internationale
donc on voit bien que sur les deux
points l'économie française va perdre du
terrain
la reprise sera nécessairement moins
fort que soi parce qu'un certain nombre
d'entreprises ont fait faillite soit
parce que les entreprises vont baisser
largement leurs investissements et donc
il y à l'évidence un problème pour la
reprise en plus nous avons aussi le
problème et banque alors en quoi est ce
que les banques seront justement
concerné dans cette affaire si vous
voulez la baisse du chiffre d'affaires
des entreprises signifie donc qu'une
partie des dettes qu'elles ont ne seront
pas remboursables en tous les cas ne
pourront pas être remboursées dans le
délai qui était prévu c'est ce qu'on
appelle en langage bancaires des prêts
non performants
autrement dit des créances douteuses
alors quand il y à une montée des
créances douteuses et il est absolument
évident que l'on aura une montée
extrêmement importante de ses créances
à partir du premier semestre de l'année
prochaine
donc quand on a une montée des créances
douteuses qu'est ce qui se passe bien
les banques sont obligées par la
législation de faire des provisions
autrement dit de réduire leur capacité à
faire des crédits et donc les banques
vont réduire les prêts qu'elle faisait
normalement aux entreprises et aux
ménages
or le problème c'est qu'une grosse
partie de ce qu'on appelle le capital
circulant autrement dit de l'argent avec
lequel on achète des marchandises on
achète des stocks etc
cet argent est empruntée donc les
entreprises feu avaient recours d'une
certaine manière au crédit bancaire
là elles ne pourront pas l'avoir où
elles seront obligées de demander
nettement moins d'argent à ses banques
ce qui va évidemment avoir un effet
dépressif important sur la reprise et
c'est peut-être là que se situe une
véritable bombe à retardement pour la
reprise française donc jacques pour vous
quand on se focalise sur la dette
publique c'est là
les états ont fait une erreur oui oui
parce que la dette publique elle peut se
régler de manière beaucoup plus simple
en fait c'est le gonflement de la dette
privée et qui est réellement inquiétant
parce que la situation financière des
entreprises
c'est en réalité ce qui va déterminer de
l'activité économique de demain vous
savez si on doit sortir de cette crise
sanitaire avec des entreprises qui
croule sous le montant de leur dette
d'une dette qu'elles ne pourront pas
pour un certain nombre d'entre elles
rembourser et bien évidemment la reprise
qui aurait dû venir après la dépression
que nous connaissons en 2020 et bien
cette reprise pourrait être très
durablement compromise je pense que le
gouvernement doit prendre conscience de
ce fait et doit s'il veut éviter
justement que la reprise n'est pas lieu
eh bien il doit agir maintenant au plus
vite merci jacques de quoi pas vraiment
nous remonter le moral mais merci quand
même merci à vous jacques sapir
on ne rend pas la gestion de la crise du
kobe 19 est différente selon les pays
confinement couvre-feu nocturne et en
journée ou même encore possible
réouverture des terrasses comme en
catalogne
les divergences s'accumulent parmi les
membres de l'union européenne alors que
se tient actuellement un sommet européen
sur la relance économique
les détails avec mehdi et ski fis en
espagne les terrasses catalan devrait
rouvrir dès la semaine prochaine alors
qu'en italie et au portugal
le couvre-feu est toujours en vigueur
des mesures sanitaires bien différente
d'un pays européen à l'autre
alors que le sommet des 27 pour le plan
de relance a lieu ce jeudi en france
l'exécutif évoque une adaptation
sanitaires à la fin du confinement pour
ne pas reproduire les mêmes erreurs
qu'au printemps
il peut y avoir et c'est ce qui est
discuté en ce moment réfléchi travaillé
qu'ils pourraient être annoncés le cas
échéant une adaptation du confinement à
partir du 1er décembre ou des jours qui
l'entourent mais nous ne sommes pas du
tout aux déconfinement on est même loin
on parle d'une adaptation éventuelle du
confinement à partir du 1er décembre si
la situation sanitaire nous le permet
des précautions qui pourrait
s'accompagner d'un prolongement de la
fermeture de certains commerces
d'après france info les bars et
restaurants français pourrait rester
fermé jusqu'au 15 janvier 2021 une date
lointaine qui pourrait encore fragiliser
le secteur déjà très impacté par la
crise du coc vide 19
ça devient quand même compliqué là parce
que si on empile des dettes des dettes
il ya un moment où ça va devenir un vrai
souci est que les banques vont plus au
sud
quoi donc il est vraiment urgent que
donc effectivement le plan de relance
soit utilisé pour sauver nos commerces
et nous aider au moins en partie sur les
loyers et tous nos contrats diverses et
variées coincé on a une perte sèche qui
est très importante
autre pays autre approche chez l'espagne
voisine en catalogne les terrasses pour
y ouvrir dès ce lundi un nouveau plan
sanitaire pour la région attendu ce
vendredi prévoit la réouverture
partielle des théâtres des cinémas des
piscines et même des salles de concert
une situation qui contraste avec le
reste du pays où le couvre-feu national
est toujours en vigueur au même titre
que l'état d'urgence sanitaire
le travail n'est pas effectuée dans une
phase de désescalade
mais un travail est en cours pour voir
comment les services fermés en raison
des restrictions actuelles peuvent être
rouverts en italie à un couvre-feu
général nocturne est toujours en place
entre 22h et 5h du matin les lycées
passe à l'enseignement à distance et les
musées reste fermé deux régions du pays
la campagne et la toscane sont classés
en zone rouge ce qui place la moitié des
italiens en confinement partiel
de son côté le portugal a mis en place
un confinement partiel avec un couvre
feu renforcé le week-end dans plusieurs
villes l'état d'urgence décrété dans le
pays jusqu'au 23 novembre pourrait être
renouvelé au-delà de cette date des pays
européens qui prennent des mesures bien
différente d'un territoire à l'autre
une absence d'harmonisation à l'échelle
du continent qui laisse apparaître des
divergences flagrante alors que se tient
le sommet de l'ue consacré au plan de
relance européen et pour contrer
l'épidémie le port du masque assez
généralisé sur une grande partie du
continent européen mais ce réflexe
comment c'est difficile à supporter pour
certains c'est le cas notamment en
allemagne pierre pissavy yvernault entre
cinq et dix mille personnes ont défilé
hier dans les rues de berlin
leur but est dénoncer les nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires alors que les
deux chambres du parlement a adopté
plusieurs me
ur pour lutter contre l'épidémie
coronavirus parmi elles le port du
masque et le respect de la distanciation
social le virus et dynamique nous devons
donc l'être également
voilà donc maintenant une loi de
protection des tiers peuple dans neuf
mois qu'ils nous donnent la possibilité
juridique de faire encore mieux face à
ce virus
en tant que gouvernement fédéral et
gouvernements des états nous avons
besoin des autorités et des outils pour
agir et prendre des décisions en ces
temps de pandémie les manifestants
accusant gala merkel de vouloir
instaurer une dictature alors que le
gouvernement tente de faire face à cette
deuxième vague plus puissante que la
première ait des protestataires pour qui
ces mesures représentent de nouvelles
entraves aux libertés individuelles
je suis ici pour mes enfants et pour mes
petits-enfants
je ne permettrai pas qu'on leur retire
leur liberté le corona virus c'est un
fake
tout ça n'a rien à voir avec le virus
désolé pour ceux qui n'ont pas encore
compris
à mon avis les restrictions sont
disproportionnées il aurait certainement
été possible de les réglementer
autrement afin que nous n'ayons pas à
subir autant de dommages les dommages
économiques ainsi que les dommages
sanitaires l'isolément qui ont également
compté beaucoup de vie plus de 13000
personnes sont mortes en allemagne
depuis le début de l'épidémie
hier près de 17000 500 cas positifs ont
été enregistrés dans le pays
la manifestation s'est terminée dans un
climat tendu est la police a tenté de
disperser la foule à coups de gaz
lacrymogènes et de canons à eau
trois cent soixante cinq manifestants
ont été interpellés selon les autorités
et aux états unis où l'épidémie de kobe
19 repart à la hausse depuis quelques
jours la ville de new york après la
décision de refermer ses écoles
publiques
il mesure qui suscite l'incompréhension
cyrielle bruit
new york a tranché alors que le pays a
franchi ce mercredi la barre des 250
mille décès le maire de la ville qui ne
dort jamais a annoncé la fermeture des
écoles publiques à compter de ce jeudi
new york seule métropole américaine à
avoir ouvert ses établissements
scolaires à la rentrée capitule face à
la hausse des cas de kovy de 19 à ce
jour sur notre moyenne mobile de 7 jours
de positivité au coronavirus la ville de
new york a atteint exactement 3 % et par
conséquent nous devons fermer nos écoles
dans les jours à venir
personne n'est heureux de cette décision
en fait nous en sommes tous très tristes
car beaucoup de travail a été fait pour
garder les écoles ouvertes
nous avons fixé une norme très clair et
nous devons nous y tenir
et je tiens à souligner aux parents aux
éducateurs aux personnels aux enfants
que nous avons l'intention de revenir et
de revenir aussi vite que possible se
passe une décision qui suscite
l'incompréhension des habitants
et pour cause la ville la plus
endeuillée aux états unis lors de la
première vague semble plutôt bien
résisté à présent malgré les 3 % de
positivité oco vite 19 l'état de new
york ainsi que la métropole
figurent parmi les moins touchées du
pays les parents d'élèves déplorent
cette décision de fermer les écoles
c'est vraiment malheureux que ses
enfants soient privés d'éducation mais
lyon peut aller dîner dans un restaurant
ça n'a aucun sens pour moi ça n'a
absolument aucun sens
cela provoque beaucoup de stress un
stress inutile nous n'avons pas besoin
de fermer les seuils le nombre de seuils
est encore bas nous sommes toujours ok
et ce n'est tout simplement pas bon pour
les parents c'est beaucoup de pression
pour nous une fermeture annoncée comme
temporaire mais dont la durée est encore
inconnu de nouvelles mesures liées à la
réouverture des écoles sont attendus
cette semaine
pour l'heure les autorités américaines
craignent une nouvelle flambée de
l'épidémie avec les célébration de
thanksgiving le 26 novembre
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis new york avec à caleb un mot pas
un correspondant d'ayrté aux etats unis
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir khaled maupin merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on referme les écoles à new york on
imagine que c'est un petit séisme dans
la ville est ce qu'on s'y attendait ce
jour il ya vraiment un sentiment de
démoralisation aux états unis les gens
ressens de la frustration envers le
gouvernement vers ses réactions
il ya beaucoup de frustration liée à
l'état de l'économie donc les gens
n'accueille pas la nouvelle de bon coeur
qu'il considère que ce nouveau
confinement est nécessaire ou pas on
imagine que c'est une décision qui n'a
pas été prise au hasard vous pouvez nous
en expliquer les raisons précises
beaucoup de cas de contamination chez
les enfants c'est bien ça
seront plus à la maison étudieront un
nouveau depuis chez eux ce qui
représente un effort supplémentaire pour
de nombreuses familles et pourrait
causer des difficultés
le système éducatif américain est une
fois de plus à l'épreuve au cours des
derniers mois il ya eu beaucoup
d'enseignement à distance dans beaucoup
d'écoles et on s'est donc ajuster au
niveau des écoles pour que cela continue
à fonctionner mais effectivement il ya
de la frustration de la part des parents
qui doivent travailler de la part des
enseignants et d'autres
la situation est mauvaise pour le pays
et c'est certains l'annoncent d'un futur
vaccin par pfizer et et modern à calais
maupin ce que c'est de nature à remettre
du baume au coeur chez ces américains
que vous décrivez comme les français
d'ailleurs très déprimée avec ces
restrictions et notamment la fermeture
des écoles à new york est ce que il ya
cette lueur d'espoir à laquelle on croit
désormais c'est assez intéressant le
débat autour des vaccins va à l'encontre
des débats autour de la vaccination
habituellement les démocrates ont
tendance à accuser les conservateurs les
partisans de donald trump d'être des
complotistes anti-vaccins de mettre en
danger la santé publique
aujourd'hui il semblerait que ce sont
les démocrates qui remettent ce vaccin
en question qui disent que peut-être
donald trump a
accélérer le processus de vaccination
pour des raisons politiques
ce sont les républicains qui font part
de leur confiance en le président et
sont prêts à se faire vacciner
ce sont donc les démocrates qui
remettent en question le vaccin
l'administration donc c'est vraiment le
monde à l'envers et cela montre qu'il ya
un peu d' hypocrisie dans cette
situation si le complot est à votre
profit alors vous l'accepter comme un
fait donc ses incohérences reflète la
façon dont les élections présidentielles
ce sont des relais l'adoption des
théories de fraude ou le fait de blâmer
des personnes telles que la russie est
ce qui rend ces accusations de fraude
acceptable ou d'autres personnes qui les
rend non acceptable vous parliez de
donald trump le même temps un autre
homme qui est accusé par joe biden de
risque et de nombreux morts parce qu ils
ne coopèrent pas justement avec les
démocrates sur cette crise du
coronavirus c'est très clair il n'y a
pas d' approche unifiée dans le pays
pour la gestion de la pandémie il ya un
fossé entre les plus acteurs principaux
certaines personnes pensent qu un
confinement irait en leur sens par
exemple les grands géants de
l'informatique
wal mart amazon aimerait se servir de ce
confinement pour assurer leur monopole
pour les petits commerces les boutiques
home depot par exemple dont les
propriétaires sont des soutiens de
donald trump pour les sociétés les
entreprises hydro fracturation qui
souffrent beaucoup des prix très bas de
l'essence il est très important de
réouvrir l'économie très rapidement
donc les grands monopoles sont en faveur
du confinement et les petits commerces
souhaiterait une réouverture très rapide
donc du fait de cette division il n'y a
pas d' approche unifiée pour la gestion
de la pandémie
chaque état décide des restrictions et
des politiques à mettre en place
joe byden accuse the donald trump blâme
donald trump pour le manque d'unité dans
les réponses à la crise l'administration
baden pourrait introduire une approche
plus unifiée mais certaines certains
acteurs résisteront car ils penseront
que cela va favoriser les grandes
entreprises les géants de la tech les
deux côtés sont donc biaisé quant à la
gestion de la pandémie les élites sont
divisés et veulent que la pandémie
soient gérées afin de leur être
favorable merci beaucoup qu'elle est non
pas un correspondant d'arte et aux etats
unis d'avoir été avec nous restez avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de la polémique née des propos
de gérald darmanin sur la nécessité pour
les journalistes de s'accréditer pour
couvrir des manifestations publiques
et puis nous parlerons des dirigeants du
conseil français du culte musulman
emmanuel macron leur donne rendez-vous
dans quinze jours pour présenter une
charte des valeurs républicaines
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tronches et
pour reprendre un code policiers il vous
a reconnu que c'est fini pour moi est ce
que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça il m'a l'air
mais quel est le rapport avec la
radiation mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
il ajouté
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même il
n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent ces
gens qui avaient envie de transmettre
quelque chose à leurs enfants qui
tout
le droite il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
mesalles imaginer la quantité de gens
qui tombent ici tous en même temps
en un instant ils sont tous tombés
c'est vraiment incroyable que tant de
soldats soient enterrés ici dans les
bois au lieu d'être chez eux avec leur
famille
quand j'étais petit ma mère m'a dit
qu'un de nos parents evgeny osipov avait
disparu avec son sous marin
il ya une torpille à tribord
on a reçu un avis de décès il a été
porté disparu au début on a attendu
un jugé par ses bottes c'est un soldat
soviétique de newsweb
je veux que le soldat soit identifié
pour qu'on puisse trouver une plaque
d'identité militaire des médailles ou
autre chose
le sort du soldat est probablement la
chose la plus importante dans nos
recherches
quand vous voyez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec cette deuxième vague
avec ce deuxième aux fines mans est ce
qu'on pouvait faire autrement plus vous
dépister - les gens meubles et ça a été
vu en allemagne quatre fois moins de
voir qu'en france ça a été vue un
autriche 4 fois moins de morts qu'on
pense à aider vu en corée du sud et
s'est empressé ne profite pas de ce
deuxième pop in man pour dépister
systématiquement les choses vont
recommencer
il y aura une troisième vague au
printemps et un troisième confinement et
ce pays sera évidemment cloués au sol
on l'a vu en doc sur le continent en
france amazon est sous le feu des
critiques accusée notamment de
concurrence est déloyale quand on
interdit tous les commerces de
fonctionner faut pas s'étonner que les
gens se tournent vers amazon jusqu'à il
serait aussi en position dominante en
décembre l'état devrait prélever à 3% du
chiffre d'affaires réalisé en france
aujourd'hui on sait on sait très bien
que ça va être très compliqué
d'appliquer une taxe gafa à des géants
comme ça qu'ils vont trouver le moyen de
passer au travers
y'a pas que ratia dumas bien posés par
les comptes des entreprises deviennent
plus puissante que des états ça pose un
souci sur la démocratie
[Musique]
21h heure française merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 19 novembre
le torchon brûle entre gérald darmanin
et la presse en cause des nécessités
pour les journalistes de se faire
accréditer auprès des autorités avant de
couvrir des manifestations sans
obligation toutefois à rectifier le
ministre de l'intérieur alors que la
liberté de filmer des policiers en
manifestations et en plein débat à
l'assemblée la possibilité des reporters
de découvrir et selon de nombreux
journalistes remise en cause
emmanuel macron leur donne rendez-vous
dans quinze jours les dirigeants du
conseil français du culte musulman
devront présenter leur charte des
valeurs républicaines reçu hier soir à
l'elysée ils ont par ailleurs présenté
les grandes lignes d'un conseil national
des imams chargé de labelliser les imams
en france le haut karabagh emmanuel
macron s'est de nouveau entretenu
aujourd'hui avec le président azéri et
le premier ministre arménien le chef de
l'état souhaite une supervision
internationale du cessez le feu par
ailleurs salué par l'union européenne
wes elle appelle désormais à enquêter
sur les supposés crimes de guerre commis
pendant le conflit
double défi logistique et enjeu
électoral au burkina faso avec
l'organisation ce dimanche d'élections
couple et les présidentielles et les
législatives
six ans après son exil l'ombre de l'ex
président blaise compaore plein toujours
sur la ligne de départ treize candidats
dont roche marc christian kaboré qui
brigue un second mandat mais aussi le
chef de file de l'opposition c'est pire
un diabré
[Musique]
faudra-t-il bientôt se faire accréditer
pour couvrir une manifestation c'est ce
que semble indiquer une récente prise de
parole du ministre de l'intérieur une
procédure contestée qui s'inscrit dans
le nouveau schéma national du maintien
l'ordre présentés en septembre dernier
tome abonnés du côté du ministère de
l'intérieur on planche depuis plusieurs
mois pour bâtir une nouvelle relation
entre les forces de l'ordre et les
journalistes sur le terrain au delà de
la polémique autour de la diffusion des
visages des policiers et gendarmes lier
la question de la présence des
journalistes lors des opérations de
maintien de l'ordre
mardi soir certains journalistes qui
couvraient la manifestation devant
l'assemblée nationale ont été menacés
d'interpellations et deux d'entre eux
ont même été placés en garde à vue
invité à réagir gérald darmanin est
revenu sur ces événements je devrais
d'ailleurs dire qu'il ya une personne
notamment un journaliste qui a fait
savoir d'ailleurs qu'il l'a fait savoir
publiquement qu'il aurait été menacé
d'être interpellé sept ce genre il ne
s'est pas rapproché de la préfecture de
police de paris contrairement à certains
de ses collègues pour couvrir cette
manifestation je rappelle donc que si
les journalistes couvrent des
manifestations notamment conformément au
schéma de match alors que j'ai évoquées
il doit se rapprocher des autorités en
l'occurrence du préfet du département
singulièrement ici préfet de police de
paris pour se signaler pour être protégé
également parlé par les forces de
l'ordre pour pouvoir être distinguée
pour pouvoir rendre compte dans ce
travail de journaliste dans ces
manifestations
le ministre de l'intérieur ensuite
twitté pour préciser sa pensée
expliquant je cite que les journalistes
peuvent sans en avoir l'obligation
prendre contact avec les préfectures en
amont des manifestations gérald darmanin
fait référence à ce document le schéma
national du maintien de l'ordre publié
le 17 septembre dernier dans lequel on
trouve notamment ses deux passages un
officier référent peut être utilement
désigne
et au sein des forces et un canal des
changes dédiées mises en place tout au
long de la manifestation avec les
journalistes titulaires d'une carte de
presse accrédités auprès des autorités
il importe à cet égard de rappeler que
le délit constitué par le fait de se
maintenir dans un attroupement après
sommation ne comporte aucune exception y
compris au profit des journalistes ou de
membres d'associations alors obligation
d'accréditation ou non difficile d'y
voir clair à ce stade
voilà en tout cas ce qui explique
l'attitude des forces de l'ordre envers
les journalistes mardi soir mais ce
document est loin de faire l'unanimité
lors de sa parution 40 sociétés de
journalistes étaient montés au créneau
contre un texte jugé comme portant
atteinte à la liberté d'informer cette
volonté d'encadrer la profession de
journaliste couplé au controversé
article 24 de la proposition de loi pour
une sécurité globale font craindre à
certains le retour au ministère de
l'information pourtant supprimée en 1974
en france alors sans en arriver jusque
là
le fait de trier des journalistes entre
ceux qui sont autorisés ou non est déjà
en soi une atteinte à la liberté
d'informer même le garde des sceaux a
laissé entendre cette semaine qu'il
voulait réviser la loi de 1881 sur la
liberté de la presse afin de lutter
contre la haine en ligne malgré un
récent rétropédalage du cabinet d'eric
dupond-moretti
voici les arguments exposés par sept
députés de la majorité pour justifier ce
choix nous devons justement comme une
protection pour les journalistes aussi
pour ceux qui font vraiment leur boulot
qu'ils font un vrai travail
d'investigation qui donne de
l'information et de la vraie information
mais s'il revient au gouvernement de
déterminer qui est journaliste ou qui ne
l'est pas ou encore d'accorder des
autorisations à tel ou tel média pour un
quelconque événement alors on peut
imaginer que certains seraient mis de
côté et on en sait quelque chose
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
didier maïsto journalistes
bonsoir didier maïsto merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france une
réaction après les propos de gérald
darmanin vous qui avez couvert beaucoup
de manifestations d gilet jaune et vous
en avez beaucoup parlé ici aussi sur ce
plateau
oui une réaction l état figé cette
réaction
en réalité qu'est ce qui se passe toutes
les personnes qui comme moi ont couvert
un certain nombre de manifestations sur
le terrain savent ce qu'il y a derrière
cette proposition de loi qui en fait ya
un projet de loi une proposition de loi
déguisé qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière la
volonté d'avoir une information
exfiltré purifier complètement neutre et
en tout cas toujours du côté de
l'exécutif parce que qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé sur le terrain à l'occasion
notamment des gilets jaunes et à leur
suite de toutes les manifestations de
fonctionnaires d'avocats un nouveau
métier en quelque sorte est né sous nos
yeux des street reporters comme on les a
appelés des gens qui ont pris leur
téléphone portable des jeunes
journalistes des gens qui n'avaient pas
forcément une carte de presse et qui de
l'intérieur ont montré ce qu'il se
passait dans le schéma des maintien de
l'ordre qui sont complètement à revoir
je rappelle quand même que il y a eu 30
éborgné quatre morts cinq mains
arrachées des arrestations arbitraires
mille gilet jaune en prison c'est une
première depuis la libération et nous
avons basculé dans une autre forme de
régime
il y avait un péché originel de ce
régime je l'avais dit avant l'élection
nous en souvenez aude emmanuel macron il
ya une fascination pour l'ordre et la
sécurité au sens italien du terme au
sens latin fashi les fâche les faisceaux
italien de l'ict heures et donc il ya
cette fascination pour l'ordre et la
sécurité la sécurité
un journaliste n'a pas être protégé un
journaliste n'a pas à être encadrés
un journaliste n'a pas à prendre ses
ordres auprès d'un exécutif un
journaliste a besoin que d'une seule
chose de liberté ça veut dire clairement
que selon l'amendement d'ailleurs qu'a
annoncé gérald darmanin déposé sur la
loi de sécurité on pourra empêcher
maintenant de films et on pourrait être
empêchés de filmer les policiers sur le
terrain
clairement mais c'est mais c'est une
évidence quand il y a eu lui il ya deux
jours la mobilisation devant l'assemblée
nationale nous avons eu en quelque sorte
un avertissement une avance une avant
première nous voyons ici les images la
loi n'est pas encore votée que vous avez
déjà des policiers qui molestent qui
violente
on a vu cette jeune anna pour taranis
news qui a été embarqué à une jeune
photoreporter de 18 ans qu'est ce
qu'elle faisait elle faisait rien de mal
elle faisait juste son métier donc si
comme le dit le ministre de l'intérieur
on peut être évacués après sommation et
il le dit lui-même il n'y aura pas
d'exception
ça veut dire qu'on ne pourra pas comment
je les fais comme d'autres l'ont fait
comme beaucoup de journalistes de rtl
ont fait être au coeur de l'événement
pour pouvoir décrypter ce qui se passe
donc là on va se contenter de
journalistes de préfecture accrédités
bien plan-plan je les ai vus mois ses
journalistes je les ai vus vous savez
comment ça s'est passé je vais souvent
dénoncés ils arrivent le matin à 9
heures les plantes les caméras en
général en haut des immeubles ils vont
faire leurs petites emplettes
les manifestations se déroulent y
reviennent à 17 heures et ils disent
assez violent il ya des black blocks il
ya des poubelles qui brûlent
mais nous qui étions sur le terrain nous
avons documenté tout ça nous avons
montré tout ça si nous n'étions pas là
il n'y aurait pas eu d'affairé nana il
n'y aurait pas eu de toutes ces affaires
de policiers
hyper violents qui se sont transformés
en ça s'est transformé en bataille de
rues à coups de poing à coup de tête
combien de gens étaient éborgné nous
avons pu documenter ce qui est arrivé à
jérôme rodrigues il était bien pacifique
sous la bastille en train de faire son
live et de dire les jeunes eux repliés
vous il ya des black blocs ont se
replierait public c'est trop dangereux
et là tout de suite poum le plogg
caractéristiques du lb d alors l'igpn
qui est littéralement une farce avait
dit que c'était
n'est ce pas un cas ou tubes d'une
grenade plus intelligent que les autres
qui avait sauté sur la chaussée et qui
manque de sens et est allée se loger
dans l'oeil
nous avons séquence par séquence toutes
les personnes qui étions là qui avons
filmé nous avons démonté cette feuille
news nous avons pu démontrer que un
policier était posté sur la droite et
avec une personne cliente ne vise pas la
tête ne vise pas la tête nous avons pu
démontrer que la grenade avait bien été
lancée au sol et qu'elle avait explosé
avant et non pas comme il a été dit au
moment où elle a touché
jérôme andriès et donc que veut ce
gouvernement bien sûr comme il est en
grande difficulté
premièrement et deuxièmement qu'il a une
fascination pour l'ordre et la cie et la
sécurité il veut exfiltrer ses mauvais
journalistes qui font un travail de
terrain pour avoir des journalistes
accrédités
avec d'ailleurs alors lui le garde des
sceaux semble avoir conscience du
problème et il essaye de trouver la
parade
il a proposé de changer en réalité le
code de procédure pénale pour faire en
sorte que toute personne qui n'est pas
journaliste puisse être convoqué en
comparution immédiate si elle est
accusée de diffuser la haine en ligne en
clair faire sortir le nom journalistes
de la loi de 1881 votre réaction
écoutez moi je suis je me méfie beaucoup
quand un gouvernement veut modifier les
lois qui fonctionne cette loi de 1881
elle fonctionne elle a été je vais pas
rappeler tout l'historique elle a été
conquise de haute lutte
et justement au départ pour interdire
pour mettre un pain une barrière entre
les pouvoirs de l'argent entre les
pouvoirs politique et la profession de
journaliste nous n'avons pas besoin
d'amendements nous n'avons pas besoin de
nouvelles lois qu'on nous foute la paix
qu'on nous laisse travailler en liberté
nous n'avons pas besoin dead nous avons
besoin d'air nous avons besoin d'oxygène
et pas de gaz lacrymogènes nous avons
besoin de liberté et pas d'injonction
voilà quelle est la vérité donc que les
seconds ici un passage de la politique
vous pas que les journalistes fassent
leur métier
vous parlez de liberté ça ressemble un
petit peu un devoir de philo de
terminale mais aujourd'hui est ce qu on
en est réduit finalement choisir entre
la sécurité notamment aussi celle des
policiers parce qu'il ya eu aussi des
blessés du côté des policiers et la
liberté
pas du tout j'entends souvent que la
première des libertés c'est la sécurité
moi je dirais que la première des
sécurités c'est la liberté
et quant aux policiers qui sont soit
disant menacés sur les réseaux sociaux
je ne dis je ne le nie pas il faut un
travail difficile et je mets pas tout le
monde dans le même panier
loin s'en faut mais il ya déjà une loi
qui existe c'est un mensonge de dire que
cette loi est là pour protéger les
policiers qui sont qui seraient jetés en
pâture comme ça sur les réseaux sociaux
je prends un seul exemple il ya eu une
une jeune fille de
21 ans une étudiante qui s'était mis en
tête de photographier les policiers de
les suivre de les poursuivre dans les
pourchasser à la fédé portrait de donner
leurs coordonnées et les afficher sur
les réseaux sociaux
elle a pris 17 mois de prison donc la
loi existe c'est pas la peine cette fois
sous l'émotion
premièrement sous l'émotion deuxièmement
sous la difficulté et troisièmement il
faut bien un jour le dire
et ce soir je le dis la police s'est
laissée complètement noyautée par des
syndicats extrêmement dur extrêmement
politisé des syndicats extrémistes je
vous invite à lire les tweets d'alliance
ou du ce du syndicat synergie du
syndicat des commissaires qui appelle
littéralement à la guerre civile et qui
font des partitions dans la population
déjà on peut se poser la question de
savoir si le seul le syndicalisme est
compatible avec la profession la mission
de policiers
admettant acceptons-en l'auguré très
bien ils ont le droit ce sont des agents
de l'état de faire avancer leur carrière
de défendre leurs droits etc
moi je je je pense qu'il faudrait bien
réfléchir si ce type d'agent peut être
syndiqués mais acceptons le fait qu'ils
soient syndiqués mais qu'ils fassent les
tournées de plateaux de télé pour avoir
des discours de haine des discours de
haine
moi j'ai les ai vus manifester quand il
était à république quand il était à
bastille se cachant l'oeil quand ils
passaient devant jérôme hourdry yes
est-ce que c'est acceptable cela en
république française
nous sommes les français sont attachés
ne sommes pas des dangereux anarchistes
des nihilistes absolue nous sommes
attachés à une police républicaine
nous sommes tous d'accord pour dire que
la police est nécessaire mais que cette
police soit république elle et qu'elle
se comporte correctement et tout se
passera bien
dernier élément on parle souvent de
l'article 24
effectivement la pousse l'impossibilité
pour les journalistes
diffusé des images qui porterait
atteinte à l'intégrité physique et
morale des policiers avec une espèce de
délits comme ça dans l'intentionnalité
confiée au juge qui devra estimer
après avoir lu young pneus et et freud
et lacan
s'il y avait bien un délit d'intention
intentionnelle de faire mal aux
policiers article 24 mai en symétrie il
y à l'article 21 qui permet aux
policiers et y compris par drones de
capter les images des citoyens en train
de manifester on sait pas où vont finir
ces images on sait pas qui les
conservera on sait pas moi j'ai pas
envie d'être filmé dans ma vie privée
et même si je manifeste et d'ailleurs la
défenseure des droits très
courageusement et ix a été très peu
souligné dans la presse
après à la suite de jacques toubon a
émis un avis très critiques très sévères
mais aussi l'onu mais aussi la ligue des
droits de l'homme mais aussi 40 sociétés
de rédacteurs
nous sommes en train de basculer dans un
régime qui ne dit pas son nom et je vous
ai parlé des faisceaux je ne vais pas
faire de grands mots vous regarderez
l'étymologie du mot faisceau c'est une
première
c'est un recul insupportable des
libertés en france et moins je vous
l'annoncé ce soir
quoi qu'il se passe je continuerai à
filmer et je continuerai à diffuser
parce que je suis dans le pays de la
liberté liberté j'écris ton nom
voilà merci didier maïsto d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france des
délégations du conseil français du culte
musulman à l'elysée
emmanuel macron leur a donné 15 jours
pour s'entendre sur une charte des
valeurs républicaines
ils ont par ailleurs présenté les
grandes lignes d'un conseil national des
imams chargé de labelliser les imams en
france
pour en parler nous sommes avec galeb
bencheikh président de la fondation de
l'islam de france bonsoir galets
bencheikh merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france emmanuel macron qui
plaide donc pour un islam des lumières
comment l'accueil et vous l'expression
n'est pas l'heure est celle du regretté
malek chebel un islam des lumières ce
que j'appelle aussi l islam de beauté
d'intelligence de spiritualité
d'élévation d'humanisme c'est possible
dans notre pays et la france mérite cet
islam là ne nous oeuvrons inlassablement
pour que ce soit le cas et nous nous
donnons les moyens pour le réaliser
parce qu'il a été possible à un moment
donné de l'histoire
il a connu un apogée civilisationnel la
concomitance de trois grands empires l'
empire ottoman empire safavi de l'empiré
moghol rien ne dit qu après la
régression tragique et il y en a eu une
véritablement puisque nous sommes hélas
en crise et c'est une crise qui a assez
duré que depuis paris depuis la france
en europe
la résurgence la réémergence de cet
islam de beauté d'intelligence ne puisse
pas se faire et elle ne se fera pour que
le sang des innocents qui étaient versés
d'effusion de sang d'être innocent lors
de ces attaques
abject terroriste du à l'islamisme
djihadistes ne soit pas vaine cette
effusion de sang
alors un conseil un galet bencheikh pour
labelliser les imams sera créée en
france
mais la question qu'on se pose c'est
comment faire entrer les imams actuelle
dans ce modèle ils élisent peut-être d'y
avoir des réticences
c'est au conseil français du culte
musulman de trouver ces critères là
d'admission et on a ce qu'ils sont on ne
peut plus simple c'est avant tout la
maîtrise de la langue nationale de la
langue française des connaissances et
des compétences théologique cultuelle
ne serait-ce que la connaissance de la
théologie classique islamique
et puis son vouloir ramener les choses à
ce que fait la fondation de l'islam de
france parce que nous donnons des
bourses et nous formons pour la partie
civile républicaine culturel laïque
ce complément de formation cultuelle il
faut bien que nos imams puisse
comprendre le fonctionnement des
institutions de la république qu'il
puisse aussi maîtriser le droit à des
cultes qu'ils sachent assumer l'héritage
français l'héritage historique et
culturel de la france j'ai eut même
l'occasion de dire non sans un brin de
provocation
il faut bien que ces imams apprennent la
geste de rollon qu'il ne fût pas tendre
vis-à-vis de la tradition religieuse
islamique c'est ça me semble-t-il qui
doit constituer les critères de
l'admission au sein de ce conseil
national des imams je préfère parler de
critères d'admission
que dalle de labellisation
j'ai entendu le lille les l'imam tareq
oubrou dire de quelle labellisation
s'agit-il
c'est vrai donc c'est une affaire de de
reconnaissance des critères de d'imama
et donc il ya des conditions à réunir et
de ce point de vue là les les imams de
france doivent véritablement avoir la
connaissance requises pour être des
thérapeutes de l'inde pour cette prise
en charge spirituelle et morale de toute
une jeunesse qu'il ne faut surtout pas
laisser comme une proie facile à des
sermoner doctrinaire à des idéologues
des aventuriers et surtout ne pas
laisser cette jeunesse aller s'abreuver
sur internet auprès du cher google 2.0
et pardonnez moi encore une fois je
reviendrai à ce que nous faisons à la
fondation de l'islam de france est pour
ça que nous avons mis en oeuvre un conte
cus numérique
une sorte de l'université digital avec
pour ambition d'être le premier site de
référence francophone afin de de
répondre aux interrogations des
musulmans et des non musulmans sur le
fait islamique et que nous ne laisserons
pas notre jeunesse
allez s'aventurer sur ce qu'ils leur
mi-août qui leur font miroiter je sais
trop quel destin ici bas ou ailleurs
dans un au delà annoncé comme meilleur
il durera alors l'objectif 1 illescas il
est connu mettre fin d'ici quatre ans à
la présence en france des 300 d'imams
étrangers détaché par la turquie le
maroc et l'algérie
est ce que ça vous semble atteignable en
tout cas je pense pour ma part qu'il est
temps d'en finir avec avec le respect
absolu que j'ai pour la dignité humaine
avec cette importation des images nous
avons la possibilité si nous ne l'avons
pas encore nous devons nous débrouiller
pour faire en sorte que nos imams soient
formés dans notre pays il n'y a aucune
raison de continuer à faire venir
certains imams ce n'est peut-être pas la
totalité qui vient sans transition qu
avec certaines idées qui ne vont pas de
pair avec l'ambiance générale avec
l'univers social psychologique français
si encore une fois je ne généralise pas
parce que toute généralisation est
abusive
s'ils viennent avec cette idée que la
société française est permis et
permissive et dépravé dissolue je ne
vois pas quel va être le sermon quel va
être le prêche qui peuvent tenir ou dire
eux du haut de leur chaire dans les
mosquées
donc il faut bien une connaissance de le
mot est à la mode un peu de l'écosystème
français et de ne pas encore une fois
faire venir des imams que ce soit du
maroc d'algérie au de turquie
particulièrement afin d'initier ou au
d'instruire au de guider ou de conduire
un office et la prière en france
merci beaucoup galère
bencheikh d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons du
haut karabagh part il souhaite une
supervision internationale du cessez le
feu par ailleurs salué par l'union
européenne
et puis direction le burkina faso
confrontées à un double défi logistique
avec l'organisation ce dimanche
d'élections couple et la présidentielle
et les législatives
[Musique]
l'état islamique a recruté dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo loups
du bataclan il y avait un état islamiste
qui semblait diriger tout ça la bascule
et se fait justement en 2015 et semis et
c'est un peu le passage de relais d'al
qaïda l'état islamique quelques pas dans
notre politique internationale vis bien
évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre de jihad
et de cet appel d'air justement on
recrutement l'a malheureusement fait en
syrie en irak
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
tout
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois le nombre de contaminés augmente
chaque semaine je pense que le système
des chu est à bout de souffle
si on ne réforme pas dans les prochaines
années les ch ur on va continuer notre
des plates le gouvernement ait
finalement pris entre deux feux il
s'agit là d'éviter une crise économique
et en même temps d'hésiter à la
propagation à du virus à jour et pas
être à la place du gouvernement français
en ce moment car y'a que des mauvaises
solutions
ce que des gens comme moi propose en ce
moment c'est que à la fin du confinement
on teste 60 millions de français
si on continue comme on fait là moi j'ai
un peu peur qu'on est coincé jusqu'à la
fin janvier
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france le
haut karabagh emmanuel macron s'est à
nouveau entretenu aujourd'hui avec le
président azerbaïdjanais
le premier ministre arménien le chef de
l'état souhaite une supervision
internationale du cessez le feu
une cessation des hostilités saluée par
l'union européenne après l'accord
négocié par la russie entre
l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie dans le même
temps bruxelles combat de l'implication
de forces étrangères dans le conflit le
chef de la diplomatie européenne a
notamment réclamé des enquêtes sur des
crimes de guerre supposés lieu demande
instamment à tous les acteurs régionaux
de s'abstenir de toute action ou de tout
discours qui pourrait compromettre le
cessez le feu et demande également le
retrait complet et rapide de tous les
combattants étrangers de la région et
enfin de points avec à notre
correspondant à moscou antoine claireaux
les dirigeants russes assure être en
contact constant avec les autorités
arméniennes et azerbaïdjanaises afin de
coordonner le règlement de l'après
conflit sans compter la présence depuis
le 10 novembre sur le terrain de force
russe de maintien de la paix et donc
depuis que les armes se sont tues
c'est l'heure des transferts de pouvoir
dans les régions concernées avec son lot
de désespoir et de chagrin pour les
populations touchées
la porte parole de la diplomatie russe a
fait le point
la population du district de kelbadjar
arrivent en masse sur le territoire
arménien en même temps des réfugiés
reviennent dans le haut-karabagh depuis
ce 14 novembre
plus de 3000 personnes en l'occurrence
3054 personnes sont revenus dans le
haut-karabagh depuis ce 13 novembre 385
corps ont été transférés par les deux
parties
nous envisageons de coopérer dans ce
domaine avec l'ol c'est eux et les
organisations internationales
compétentes telles que le comité
international de la croix rouge
le haut commissariat des nations unies
pour les réfugiés le haut commissariat
des nations unies aux droits de l'homme
l'unesco notre part on entendu ici et là
des réserves émises par washington et
paris concernant la signature de ce
cessez-le-feu sans leur participation
alors quand les faits la russie la
france et les états unis font tous trois
partie du groupe de minsk censée depuis
près de 30 ans trouver une solution
pacifique aux
conflit dans le cauca rabat le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères a tenu à
clarifier les choses
doha 11 deux jours j'ai parlé deux fois
avec le ministre français des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian
j'ai essayé de lui expliquer que notre
but était de mettre fin aux morts de
faire en sorte que les gens ne soient
plus ou si à quitter leur maison que le
nombre de réfugiés et de personnes
déplacées je n'augmente pas par dizaines
de milliers à amiens auteurs pourquoi il
n'est pas correct d'un point de vue
moral et éthique de brice rocher le fait
de ne pas avoir rappelé washington ou
paris affichent toujours leur demander
s'ils soutenaient que telle ou telle
formulation qui au moment où chaque
minute compte pour sauver des vies nick
hayek initi les membres de ce groupe de
minsk eux s'accordent à dire que ce
cessez le feu est une étape importante
mais qu'il reste encore beaucoup de
chemin à parcourir notamment pour
arriver à une solution politique durable
et viable et en particulier la
négociation du statut de ce qu'il reste
du haut karabagh arménien alors quelles
répercussions sur la france pour éviter
de froisser les communautés
azerbaïdjanaise et arménienne le pays
doit se livrer à un numéro
d'équilibriste
un équilibre qui pourrait être compromis
par les initiatives de certains
sénateurs ou du conseil de paris écoutez
comment avec estelle fages
nous sommes dans une relation d' accord
d'amitié entre paris erevan mais aussi
bien sûr ça a été rappelé au sein de
l'aïe et m vous l'avez dit la situation
particulièrement
dramatique nous a poussés les uns et des
autres est d'ailleurs pas simplement
dans cet hémicycle je constate que au
sénat et dans d'autres lieux de la
république des positions sont en train
d'être prises avec 90 voix pour et 40 3
abstentions le conseil de paris s'est
prononcée en faveur de la reconnaissance
du caractère arméniens du haut karabagh
une initiative qui n'est pas du goût de
l'azerbaïdjan dans une lettre adressée à
la mairie de paris l'ambassadeur de la
république azéri estime que ce voeu est
contraire à certains principes du droit
international
ce voeu est contraire aux engagements
internationaux européens bilatéraux et
au droit national et international
en effet intel veut porte une atteinte
illégale à plusieurs principes du droit
international notamment celui
d'intangibilité des frontières
ces initiatives qui propose de
reconnaître l'ars arleux non arméniens
du haut karabagh comme appartenant à la
république d'arménie se sont multipliés
ces derniers jours une proposition en ce
sens devrait être présenté au sénat le
25 novembre prochain à l'initiative de
bruno retailleau une résolution signée
par les présidents des groupes de droite
du centre et de gauche sera présentée au
vote au sénat le 25 novembre
elle propose la reconnaissance de la
république arménienne d'art sarre afin
de la protéger de l'expansionnisme turc
la communauté franco azerbaïdjanaise a
de son côté interpellé le ministre des
affaires étrangères jean yves le drian
elle dénonce une hystérie anti
azerbaïdjan et demande à la france de
réaffirmer son impartialité et le chef
de la diplomatie française l'a martelé
dès le mois d'octobre notamment aux élus
la france doit rester neutre dans ce
dossier arguant de sa nécessaire
impartialité liée à son statut de
médiateurs mais certaines initiatives on
vient de le voir semble avoir mis à mal
la volonté de jean yves le gall
alors la france peut-elle vraiment
conserver cette fameuse neutralité qui
arrange rich jean yves le drian appelle
de ses voeux et peut-être un peu trop
tard dans ce dossier alors même qu'un
cessez le feu a été trouvé sous l'égide
de la russie entre l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en parler nous
sommes avec philippe kalfayan juriste
créateur du barreau de la république
d'arménie bonsoir philippe kalfayan
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
zahour sadig billy avocat spécialiste du
droit hantatiana siona halle et droit
des étrangers bonsoir monsieur merci
d'être avec nous également on l'a vu en
tout un symbole le sénat français qui a
donc décidé de demander la
reconnaissance de la république du haut
karabagh c'est une victoire pour la
communauté arménienne philippe kalfayan
écoutez je suis à erevan en ce moment
mais de toute façon ce n'est pas c'est
un voeu qui est exprimée je crois ce
n'est pas encore la reconnaissance mais
c'est un processus normal on peut
considérer que l'azerbaïdjan a perdu le
droit au respect de son intégrité
territoriale
parce que elle n'a pas respecté les
principes du droit à l'autodétermination
un droit qui est un droit impératif en
droit international
c'est ce qu'on appelle du jusqu'au 15 et
et en l'occurrence l'azerbaïdjan 1-1 n'a
pas respecté les trois critères qui
aurait pu donc lui donner droit à ce que
on concilie à la fois le droit à
l'autodétermination des arméniens du
karabagh et le droit à l'intégrité
territoriale de l'azerbaïdjan
ces trois critères ont été définis
un par la cour suprême du canada quand
elle a eu à s'exprimer sur la sécession
du québec donc de la fédération
canadienne
il y en a trois critères c'est
premièrement le manquement au respect
donc des principes de représentation de
l'ensemble de la population donc d'un
état le deuxième critère c'est des
violations flagrantes des droits
fondamentaux de l'homme et en
particulier quand il s'agit de menace
sur l'intégrité physique des populations
et enfin le troisième critère il est
bien évident c'est quand il n'y a plus
de possibilité d'avoir un règlement
pacifique donc de l'âme delà du
règlement du conflit
bon laser vesion finalement fait la
démonstration par elle-même que
bah elle avait perdu son droit à
l'intégrité territoriale
il est tout à fait légitime que les
arméniens aujourd'hui face à reconnaître
effectivement cette autodétermination de
manière unilatérale
alors cette résolution sur le
haut-karabagh dont on parle c'est est à
la base une proposition de valérie boyer
la sénatrice les républicains étaient
d'ailleurs venus sur notre antenne il y
a un mois pour en parler pour elle il
fallait s'engager je vous propose de
l'écouter dé ce nom tout disait que être
neutre c'est choisir son camp et est ce
que la france est ce que l'europe
peuvent choisir le camp de la barbarie
est ce que la france est ce que l'europe
peut tolérer qu'il y ait encore haut
karabagh qu'il y ait encore pour les
arméniens du haut-karabakh et d'arménie
à nouveau génocide parce qu'on sait que
malheureusement en plus de tuer des
humains
l'azerbaïdjan et ça et d'effacer toutes
les traces de la présence arménienne qui
est pourtant ancestrale qui est qui date
de plusieurs siècles en a les moyens il
ya des mots très durs un génocide
les arbitres gens qui essayerait
d'effacer toutes les traces de la
présence arménienne qu'est ce que vous
lui répondez à urs hany baghli écoutez
moi je constate à nouveau qu'il a une
hystérie collective hystérie collective
arménienne bon monsieur le préfet il dit
qu'il est juriste international il nous
présente décision du cour suprême du
canada il parle de trois principes
moi si je vais plus de temps on peut le
balayer tous ces arguments
moi je jeune j'ai attentivement écouté
ses arguments je les ai bien pris un
autre des trois principes qu'il décrit
là où quand je vois que l'azerbaïdjan
n'a violé il faut quand même arrêter de
raconter n'importe quoi
bien sûr on peut parler de l'histoire
vous savez monsieur k 1 fry on ne va pas
aller beaucoup de choses vous ayez
rêvant mais moi aussi je suis derrière
aimant je suis né à erevan et ma famille
et de erevan et tous mes ancêtres
habitait révolte et au début de siècle
dernière il avait 96 % d algérie en eux
que je peux vous expliquer comment ma
famille a été expulsée et qui sont
devenus mes compatriotes à erévan keith
ont été massacrés expulsé donc on va pas
encore faire rentrer dans les détails
mais même moi je connais des chiffres et
des délits
car je connais 217 de mecs comme ses
compatriotes qui ont été assassinés
massacrés en arménie et 350 milles azéri
qui s'en est excusé de l'armee mettant
pas son nouveau principe quand vous
dites que il a manquement d'un droit des
personnes
mais attendez les invasions nous violé
aucun droit les âges les arméniens du
haut karabagh il bénéficiait toujours
cette autonomie et d'ailleurs je pense
mon intime conviction que c'était déjà
un très grand compromis au début de
siècle
parce que ce qui se passe au haut
karabagh que des cinq premiers
secrétaires des parties de cinq régions
du karabagh les quatre est arménien dont
qu'ils bénéficient de subventions
il veut comme les rois le karabagh et
des plus développés que l'azerbaïdjan en
effet certains régionaux série a ne faut
pas raconter n'importe quoi
donc quand vous dites qu'il avait menace
sur l'intégrité physique des personnes
où donc de droits des personnes ça aussi
je peux pas accepter
on peut rappeler on peut vous rappeler à
vous et à vos anciens dirigeants ceux du
cabba et de l'arménie
le crime de génocide de khodjali que
commis par les arméniens
et ça a été documenté avec l'aide de 360
6e régiment d'infanterie mobile russe
qui a été dissous par l'état russe
parce que la russie ait été choqué même
si ça semble ministre de défense était
avec les origines arménien ça a été
choqué les rues surtout choqué quand le
régime en entier à passer du côté
arménien et 26 février 92 300 613 fonde
pas entend enfin étaient massacrés des
membres et les femmes les femmes
enceintes éventrées
elle est elle effectue sans broncher sa
mission n'a pas oublié on n'oubliera
jamais donc les conséquences ce qui pèse
aujourd'hui il faut peser ses mots quand
valérie boyer et les autres je pense que
je pèse mes mots
andy à leurs représentants élus français
en digne puisqu'il allait et j'ai créé
plusieurs fort aux élus français et au
président de la république quand il a
les mots il faut les choses savoir
choisir quand vous dites qu ici à vos
intérêts électoralistes au dessus des
intérêts de la france il faut un pc des
mots comme on dit le jeune au sud
ils font payer vous voyez c'est reparti
quelle fille on sait où on va on va lui
donner là c'est un débat c'est un débat
le cher monsieur amoureux de nibali on
va à l'essai
répondre tout de même philippe kalfayan
qui vous a laissé parler on va vous
redonner la parole après à vous écouter
moi j'ai d'abord du français
je ne suis pas des rivales deuxièmement
je n'ai pas parlé d'histoire mais je
remarque que mon contradicteur lui est
remonté à l'histoire d'elias en temps on
aurait pu aller sur ce terrain là et
j'aurais pu dû démontrer que cette
époque là ce territoire n'était pas
azerbaïdjanais mais donc et est en fait
mon contradicteur est parti sur
l'histoire ou sur l'invectivé vis-à-vis
des élus français mais il n'a absolument
pas abordé le problème de droit
international et il serait bien normal
d'ailleurs de démontrer le contraire de
ce que je viens de d'exposer voilà donc
aux ja la démonstration la du discours
du discours vindicatif violent qui s'est
traduit d'ailleurs dans les faits lors
de l'agression
mais aussi d'une manière générale dans
la glorification de tous les actes
cruels qui sont commis par l'azerbaïdjan
depuis quelques quelques 20 20 ans
pourra pour rappel la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme à a condamné un
donc en 2020 l'azerbaïdjan pour avoir
donné une médaille et glorifier un
officier azéri qui à budapest sur une
base donc de formation de l'otan avait
tué dans son sommeil un arménien à coups
de hache
ouais c'est c'est donc la barbarie dont
par valérie boyer n'est pas une chimère
c'est pas inventé la nasa
l'argent a été condamné pour cet acte
ignoble lâche d'ailleurs et vous ne
pourrez pas dire le contraire
et ce n'est pas les armes et qu'ils le
disent c'est la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme alors en tout cas
l'azerbaïdjan a clairement demandé au
journaliste français de renommée les
noms des villes et villages je cite des
régions libérées de la république d
azerbaïdjan
je vous propose de regarder ce courrier
de l'ambassade envoyés dans toutes les
rédactions françaises
chers journalistes des médias français
au cours des derniers jours
l'usagé des mots incorrecte des villes
des villages et des régions libérées de
la république d azerbaïdjan de
l'occupation par les forces arméniennes
est observée dans les médias français
à cet égard l'ambassade de la république
d azerbaïdjan et en république française
à l'honneur de porter à votre attention
ci dessous le tableau des noms corrects
et vous prie de bien vouloir utiliser
dans vos articles et reportages les noms
corrects selon ce tableau n'est pas tout
seul r prendre je pense que je n'aurai
pas un bon accent la ville de chouchi
devient choucha par exemple la ville de
bergues nord devient latchine en tout
plus d'une dizaine de villes ce sont des
des traces culturelles qui sont effacées
on comprend peut-être la douleur de ces
arméniens sahour a dit écoutez moi je
comprends bien sûr le dealer des
personnes qui sont obligées de partir
par exemple de kelbadjar mais il faut
pas oublier que qu'elle belge axel et
hérite en azerbaïdjan et le gouvernement
azerbaïdjanais il a dit depuis le début
que marielle on n'a aucun grief à faire
aux arméniens civile qui veulent vivre
en azerbaïdjan en effet les personnes
qui sont vécues en azerbaïdjan sont au
citoyen et elle peut vivre et bénéficier
des mêmes droits
mais le problème aujourd'hui et il faut
qu'une mission khalfa tient aussi
compenser cette situation c'est si je
peux me permettre on peut faire pas à
l'aise avec les séparatismes en france
aucun pays dans le monde n'acceptera sur
son territoire des personnes
séparatistes qui vont prendre valaisan
et par la force des armes vous détacher
d'une partie de votre territoire
les arméniens duquel bahdja qu'ils ont
occupés lequel belge à qui n'était pas
leur région ils se sont installés ils
sont pensés que qu'elle va devenir leur
a jamais je reviens d'un autre
mais quelle fatigue en bout du droit
international si vous voulez rester
légaliste
on va rester sur l'acte final d'helsinki
1,2175 et que tous les pays on signe en
tout cas 38 au moment de signature de
tous les documents postérieurs et même
le document de communauté des états
indépendants que l'arménie elle même
assignée donc danser tous ces documents
et et tous les autres arguments des arts
mines soit disant que le karabagh a eu
l'indépendance avant de l'azerbaïdjan
les chiffres montrent le contraire
les arv agent est devenu indépendant
avant que le haut karabagh ces problèmes
et indépendante
donc vous savez tous ces documents sion
on les balaie d'un revers
il faut rester dans le cadre
international même la charte des nations
unies
quand vous voulez parler d'auto
détermination je pense que vous vous
voulez vous en prendre à l'article 3 4
des charte des nations unies
nous n'oublions pas que charte des
nations unies pour l'autodétermination
il concerne principalement des peuples
sans état ça veut dire les peuples
qu'ils ont pas leur propre état or les
arméniens du haut-karabakh
ils peuvent pas bénéficier de cette
situation tous tout simple raison que
laure et ta mère c'est l'arménie et si
on revient poule haut karabagh encore
une fois il faut arrêter de dire dans
les médias aidant l'aident dans cette
propagande pro arménien que la halle au
karabagh a été donnés à l'azerbaïdjan
lyzel à la décision de 5g 1921 certes le
bureau politique du parti communiste
certes mais il a marqué l'essai le haut
karabagh dans l'azerbaïdjan et si vous
voulez mais tant l'histoire on peut
aller encore plus loin on peut aller au
traité de curé de chiens de 14 mai 1805
selah sue juridique du karabagh c'est le
crâne à cazères et qui a été rattaché à
la russie et si vous vous lisez ce texte
il est marqué que le tsar russe le
gouvernement russe a garanti à haut
karabagh qu'ils restent eux khaled
l'azéri et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
les russes ils vont ils ont respecté ça
si vous êtes à l'elysée les articles d
décemment imminente comprendrait reshad
ils arrivent à la même conclusion
laroussi finalement avec l'europe et de
200 ans on voit qu'il a tenu la promesse
le haut karabagh il est resté azéri
alors ce qui se passait par rapport aux
populations civiles puisque vous n'aimez
pas ces thèmes il se passait que les
trans migration massive des arménienne
après traitait de tout match et de
gulistan et de corruption a commencé sur
le territoire azéri y compris le tueur
le territoire de trouve ouvert mes
ancêtres
et quand on arrive au début du siècle je
veux parler ici de jeunes
si darwin et je sais que c'est un débat
12 euros et là et je pense que la
turquie a fait un pas courageux à ouvrir
tous les archives ottomanes
mais un jour le débat prospérera mais ce
qui concerne les j'ai écrit déjà ça ce
qui concerne moi mon peuple ce qui
concerne à l'azerbaïdjan que cet échec
qui a eu dans la lenteur aurait un taxi
se retourner contre nous puisque les
arméniens ils pas il faisait ce jour de
l'entente faire couler l'empiré ottoman
de l'intérieur et bénisse et de grandes
arménien mais quand c'est l'échec est ce
qu'ils ont fait en panique que les
autres il est revenu sur le territoire
des anciens kanata série de demandes
arménien est plus lent jusqu à bas coûts
ils ont massacré les airs et partout
pour libérer la place 313 milles azéri
tué total cinquante mille à bas coûts
donc là on oublie ça bien sûr et
l'histoire malheureusement avec le
conflit de haut karabakh il se répétait
je parlais tout à l'heure de jeu jallet
même est non seulement de quoi que
j'allais vous savez dans une seule
maison sympa données bien mais il fait
où l'on crée c'est un des bars et c'est
un débat on va laisser le mot de la fin
pour philippe kalfayan oui bah écoutez
je remarque encore une fois qu on sait
qu'à partait du sujet avec cette fois ci
un discours négationnistes comme
d'habitude on est parti sur génocide des
arméniens commis par la turquie et
monsieur pas dans un discours
négationniste qui n'a pas sa place dans
ce débat et ça montre bien ça montre
bien que tout cet exposé est en fait
contraire à ce qu'il veut démontrer en
tout état de cause le droit
international est très clair le droit à
l'autodétermination est un droit qui en
théorie je dis bien en théorie dans les
écrits du droit sont un processus
interne aux étapes et là nous sommes
bien d'accord sauf que quand justement
cet état ne procède pas au processus
démocratique d'autodétermination des
individus eh bien ces individus
ce peuple a le droit de faire valoir son
droit à l'autodétermination externe
ce qu'on appelle la sécession et j'ai
donné les trois critères qui sont
aujourd'hui prévue par le droit
international pour qu'un peuple mettre
fin à l'oppression à la discrimination
de l'état dans lequel il se trouve
voilà et donc aujourd'hui c'est ça le
débat et c'est pas d'histoires que vous
êtes en train de refaire / / / leur à la
barre s'il ya 100 ou du 19e siècle
parce que les historiens pourraient vous
démontrer que c'est une terre ancestrale
arménienne et donc c'est hors sujet
aujourd'hui il ya eu une guerre vous
avez utilisé la force
vous avez gagné la bataille militaire
mais vous avez perdu vos droits donc sur
ce territoire dur à la barre historique
les arméniens ont droit à notre
détermination sur ce territoire
et c'est ce qu'ont rappelé les trois
pays médiateurs du groupe de minsk en
disant qu'il fallait discuter maintenant
du statut final du haut karabagh merci à
tous les deux vous les recettes ou les
deux fils kalfayan zahour sadig ben ali
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce débat est
on est on termine avec le burkina faso
se tiendra ce dimanche le premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle six ans
après son exil l'ombre de l'ex président
blaise compaore plein toujours en ces
derniers jours de campagne
l'ambiance s'anime quelque peu à
ouagadougou les détails avec les îles à
saraf sur la ligne de départ treize
candidats dont roch marc christian
kaboré qui brigue un second mandat mais
aussi le chef de file de l'opposition
zéphirin diabré dans les rues de la
capitale ouagadougou les partisans du
président sortant espère sa victoire au
premier tour de la présidentielle de ce
dimanche un coup ko
selon l'expression ouest africaine en
vogue depuis une dizaine d'années la
campagne se passe très bien
et je pense que vous verrez un coup ko
pour le 28 novembre je pense que ça va
être un peu difficile mais il faut que
les forces de l'autre fasse gaffe à tous
les parcs de vote
parce que là vraiment on a besoin de
sécurité pour que ça se passe près les
nombreux opposants croient eux un second
tour possible malgré un contexte
sécuritaire tendu dans une grande partie
du pays
j'en ai parlé d'un coup ko mais
plaisante matisse en quelque chose
d'assez piles evolta op pas su passer
aux climats passés ici j'ai confiance à
bord candidats et dit combien je sais de
quoi il est capable
pourquoi je pense à lui pourquoi parce
que bon nombre et aussi si halak il ya
beaucoup de gars qui sont ici ça balance
pas c'est du passé
cette élection présidentielle est
couplée avec des législatives très peu
de grands meetings ont eu lieu en raison
de la pandémie de kovy de 19 et de la
peur d'attac jihadistes et c'est la fin
de cette émission se retrouve dans
quelques minutes pour 1 point complet
sur l'actualité
[Musique]
on l'a vu un depuis le continent en
france amazon est sous le feu des
critiques accusée notamment de
concurrence est déloyale quand on
interdit tous les commerces de
fonctionner on pas s'étonner que les
gens se tournent vers amazon s'était pas
maso jesse crain autres il serait aussi
en position dominante en décembre l'état
devrait prélever à 3% du chiffre
d'affaires réalisé en france
aujourd'hui on sait on sait très bien
que ça va être très compliqué
d'appliquer une taxe gaza à des géants
comme ça qu'ils vont trouver le moyen de
passer au travers
ya pas qu ratia du magazine ils ont du
mal aussi à être performant d'avoir bien
posée par lydia comptes des entreprises
deviennent plus puissante que des états
ça pose un souci sur la démocratie
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même à
l'époque il y avait une concurrence qui
était assez violente d'ailleurs entre
les russes et les américains alors que
j'étais destinée à voler avec les russes
mais une opportunité s'est ouverte de
faire partie du deuxième groupe
d'astronautes européens qui m'a envoyé
aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles à en est quand même
dans une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
doux sans le faire